bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de ski mag
la crise sanitaire n'a pas freiné les
envies d'innovation à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cinq grandes
entreprises s'allient afin d'inventer la
mobilité de demain à travers la software
république
les start-up innove également soutenu
par le territoire elles ont été mises à
l'honneur du sprint 50 de paris saclay
et puis la 5g arrive sur l'agglomération
en vue des jeux olympiques 2000 24 ont
fait le tour des innovations
saint-quentinoise c'est parti
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire n'a pas stoppé
l'innovation territoire entreprises
universités oeuvre plus que jamais
ensemble pour créer et innover
à commencer par le groupe automobile
renault au sein de son technocentre de
guyancourt
un labo géant est sorti de terre
le bâtiment odyssée c'est ici que sera
conçu la mobilité de demain à travers la
software république
renault s'est associé à quatre autres
entreprises de renault l'idée c'est de
créer un écosystème qui va travailler
sur les logiciels
[Musique]
pourquoi travailler sur les logiciels
parce que les logiciels finalement c'est
la valeur future du véhicule de demain
et de la mobilité de demain
on aurait pu le faire tout seul on a
préféré s'associer à des champions parce
qu'on pense qu'on sera beaucoup plus
efficace et beaucoup plus fort sur ces
ensembles simulation de flux bornes de
recherche compatible pour tous les
véhicules électriques
chaque entreprise participante apportera
sa technologie propre et son
savoir-faire grands groupes et start up
du territoire vont chacune mettre leur
pierre à l'édifice
on est observée au début du plateau de
saclay et le plateau de saclay c'est un
plateau d'intelligence d' expertise de
grands entreprises de centres de
recherche des meilleures universités
françaises et donc on aura cette
proximité
on a aussi sur le plateau de saclay
beaucoup de startups qui sont déjà
actives dans les domaines qui nous
intéresse l'intelligence artificielle la
cybersécurité et donc on pense qu'on va
pouvoir capitaliser autour de nous et
autour du bâtiment odyssée qui sera
inaugurée en septembre prochain un
projet dont se félicite alexandra
rosetti vice présidente en charge du
développement économique sur
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise on a
bien vu avec cette crise aussi que le
ralentissement les flux automobile en
particulier était vecteur de de bien
être aussi pour les pour les habitants
[Musique]
la mobilité elle doit évoluer je crois
que c'est de toute façon ce qu'attendent
de tous nos habitants ce qu'attendent
nos entreprises aussi il faut absolument
s'appuyer sur l'innovation pour faire
quelque chose de durable
saint-quentin accompagne toujours ces
entreprises dans leur recherche de deux
d'implantation et vient en soutien
en tout cas à toutes les entreprises qui
souhaitent faire de l'innovation elle
vient elle y ait un soutien on a des
services dédiés
notre idée aussi à saint quentin c'est
justement de de biens hérités ce terme
de terre d'innovation il ya une vraie
volonté justement parce que parce qu'on
est très attaché à ce territoire et au
fait que son développement économique se
poursuive et qu'il soit toujours aussi
attractif pour les entreprises qui sont
à la pointe des technologies
les start up nous l'avons vous sont
également sollicités pour participer au
développement des nouvelles technologies
nous avons rencontré deux d'entre elles
ici sur le territoire saint quentinois
pour qu'elle nous parle de leurs
innovations
rendez vous tout d'abord dans les locaux
d'auxi boxe à guyancourt
créée en 2014 par un consultant en
informatique et cyber sécurité après un
constat les solutions de sauvegarde des
données était structurellement non
sécurisés et qu'elle était complexe et
coûteuse a opéré sa start up est lancé
[Musique]
auxi box est une solution de cyber
résilience faire c'est une solution qui
permette de pouvoir opérer le
redémarrage d'un système d'information
complet en temps extrêmement rapide
après attaqueront soir après une attaque
de ce type plusieurs questions se posent
les sauvegardes sont elles exploitables
et complète boxée box propose des tests
automatisés et régulier sans omettre la
vitesse de restauration des données
le quatrième point sur lequel on a
travaillé c'est que même si vous donnez
sont accessibles même sous pour
restaurer rapidement vous ne pouvez pas
restaurée sur les machines qui ont été
touchés par la cyberattaque que votre
système d'information et sujet en fin de
compte comme un train d'incendier un
retour de flamme temps car ce moment là
on va dire que les pompiers sont sur
place
le coeur de cible du pompier auxi box
sont les pme tpe
depuis 2014 la start-up enregistre plus
de 100 % de croissance par an et
poursuit son recrutement
l'entreprise devrait doubler d'ici à fin
au sein de l'incubateur ski cuba
guyancourt nous avons rencontré olivier
ruches au fondateur et président de la
start-up portique cortix propose une
solution pour les agriculteurs qui est
une solution de simplification et
d'automatisation de la traçabilité à
l'école
[Musique]
c'est l'enregistrement de tout ce qui de
toutes les actions et les produits qui
ont été utilisées pour produire les
végétaux et année la récolte notre
solution s'adresse d'abord à
l'agriculture de plaine donc ce qu'on
appelle la grande culture ça peut
intéresser aussi bien d'autres cultures
conventionnelles qui utilisent des
engrais minéraux ou des pesticides mais
également l'agriculture biologique
mais la solution d'oryx ne se limite pas
à la traçabilité
c'est une acquisition de données
simplifiée sur le terrain qui ne permet
de savoir dans le détail tout ce qui a
été fait le temps que ça a pris les
moyens qui ont été mis en oeuvre pour le
réaliser pour ensuite développer des
outils des de pilotage de l'exploitation
agricole
les outils agronomiques et économiques
aideront l'agriculteur dans ses prises
de décision
ceci pour permettre à l'exploitant de se
détacher de ses contraintes
réglementaires et se concentrer sur son
coeur de métier créée en février 2019
or tic se recherche actuellement un
directeur commercial pour accélérer son
développement
ces deux entreprises du territoire saint
quentinois avaient été sélectionnés pour
participer au sprint 50 les 20 et 21 mai
dernier lors de la troisième édition de
ce prime paris saclay l'événement dédié
à l'innovation et à l'excellence
scientifique mettait ainsi à l'honneur
les startups les plus performantes parmi
lesquels six étaient saint-quentinoise
on est très fier de faire partie cette
sélection ce prime cinq ans qui valorise
effectivement nos efforts en innovation
on a fait plus de cinq ans de recherche
développement sur ce sur ce sur ce
produit
donc on est extrêmement fiers d'avoir pu
le développer sur fonds propres
jusqu'ici à saint quentin en yvelines
paris saclay effectivement un endroit
formidable pour être start up avec un
environnement extrêmement porteur qui
contribue à faire image et donc
effectivement des start up et de réussir
leur transformation leur skyblog
puisqu'on parle de skyler après la
start-up saint quentin en yvelines en
particulier c'est un territoire
d'innovation extrêmement important pour
la cybersécurité
comme nous sommes une entreprise du
secteur de la cybersécurité il est
effectivement on n'aurait pas imaginé
meilleur environnement pour pour se
développer
le sprint 50 soit déjà ca
la satisfaction d'une reconnaissance la
reconnaissance du fait que artix et jugé
être une start up qui a du potentiel
pour nous c'est vraiment une grande
satisfaction que d'avoir pu convaincre
que ce qu'on propose a du sens et a du
potentiel
c'est un moyen de nous faire connaître
c'est une opportunité de rencontrer à
des structures de financement des
business angels des investisseurs une
fierté également pour le territoire
saint quentinois
outre le fait de voir des fleurons de
l'industrie saint-quentinoise ouvrir ses
portes il y a aussi les startups porté
par l'agglomération dans ces startups
qu'on retrouve des pépites
saint-quentinoise puisque nous avons
aussi notre propre incubateur un appel à
candidatures avait été lancé malgré la
crise sanitaire en février 2021
permettant d'accueillir quatre nouveaux
projets on entre dans une nouvelle phase
on a enrichi notre incubateur dont il y
avait l'accompagnement et maintenant on
a également un programme d'accélération
qui permet d'apporter des expertises
supplémentaires mais à des start up qui
elles sont déjà dans phase 2 qui ont été
créées qui commence à générer du chiffre
d'affaires mais qui ont besoin d'être
accompagnés sur des domaines qui peuvent
être juridique ressources humaines
financiers et bénéficier je dirais
d'elle et d'accompagnement
supplémentaires
un autre appel à candidatures vient
d'être lancée jusqu'au 28 juin prochain
autre innovation en cours à saint
quentin en yvelines la 5g après les
premiers tests réalisés en décembre 2020
une plateforme développée par nokia a
été lancé c'est effectivement un
événement majeur principalement
orientées c'est important de le dire sur
l'aspect industriel
[Musique]
puisque effectivement c'est ce qui va
permettre de l'entreprise
sur place on a des filles est important
de l'automobile du bâtiment de pouvoir
entrer dans la révolution industrielle
je dirais 3.0 c'est à dire utiliser les
données utilisées la vidéo
l'automatisation les robots pour pouvoir
effectivement être un petit peu plus
productifs la candidature de saint
quentin en yvelines à la recette avait
reçu l'appui des entreprises du cluster
paris saclay le choix de
l'expérimentation au vélodrome nationale
n'est pas un hasard
il s'agit d'être fin prêt pour certains
grands événements à venir
l'idée c'est de pouvoir utiliser les
avantages de la singer à savoir la
rapidité de passage des informations est
ce qu'on appelle la latence c'est à dire
le délai en ce temps de transfert qui
ont deux avantages voire de la 100g pour
pouvoir éventuellement utiliser la
plateforme du vélodrome comme un outil
de communication visuelle différent pour
les spectateurs qui pourrait y est c'est
à dire pourquoi pas sur des vélos à
avoir des capteurs de caméras des
capteurs de rythme cardiaque qui
permettrait en temps réel à chaque
spectateur de pouvoir voir pour chaque
coureur où on en est s'immerger dans la
course et encore une fois le sol une
terre d'innovation à saint quentin en
yvelines et nous souhaitons pouvoir est
à la pointe de la technologie et à
inventer
[Musique]
ce qui m'a guînes ovation s'est terminée
après bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]